all right carlos
carlos uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um i'm from mainland
california
i grew up around this area south central
lane
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young um
no my both of my parents were drug
addicts
um when i was about
i think maybe like nine
my my dad came home high on pills and
back then they used to use reds
instead of heroin and uh he was beating
he was beating the [ __ ] on my mom
so i knew where he kept his gun at i
went to the closet
grabbed the gun i came back and i shot
him i didn't i didn't shoot him
intentionally like he liked to like to
hit him i just aimed it
shot and i wanted to hit him in the
chest and he wanted to go to the
hospital and
nobody never told me anything about him
after that
he survived that i don't know you don't
know
they never mentioned anything to me
about it you were nine
yeah never saw him again no
no my mom never mentioned anything about
it my grandparents either
because during that time my grandparents
they took me and the sister that i have
this
this next youngest they adopted us
to get us away from my mom because she
got me started on heroin when i was 10
years old
yeah so a lot of violence in your
childhood yeah yeah
i grew up around violence and i lived
divided in
you know join a gang at some point yeah
um the gang thing
all my foul all my family members
they're they're they're from the same
gang
so i really didn't have to join a gang
i was pretty much born into it
you know so i mean i i started putting
in work without when i was when i was
really young
what age did you start probably probably
around eight nine years old
i started and uh how far are you in
school
i didn't go i didn't go to school first
i didn't start going to school till
maybe i think when i was like
12 years old 12 years old everything i
learned from the streets
i wanted getting juvenile life and
that's when i started i started going to
school
when i was 15 i wanted hitting prison i
got out of
doing a juvenile life i was out a month
and wound up you know robbing and
kidnapping
an off-duty sheriff we didn't even know
he was a cop
my crime you got away and i i i was the
one that wanted to get arrested for it
you know because i was a juvenile you
know the judge
had the d.a and my grandparents and some
sheriffs
go and get me out of the county jail
because back then this was like in the
early 80s
when they said that they couldn't find
you they lost you in the system
they lost you in the system and what
they were doing there they were pulling
me out every night around
11 12 o'clock and beating [ __ ] out of me
every day
you know what i mean every day and i was
so [ __ ] up that i couldn't go to court
so they would just say they couldn't
find me or i was lost somewhere and
you know that's how that's how they had
me for about
about two months until the judge finally
ordered the date to go
to go find me or else the judge said
that
he was going to lock up the d.a you know
what i mean
so they went they they got me the judge
was really upset
because i was a minor and i should have
been there you know but i always looked
a little bit older for my age i had a
mustache and everything
so the cops said they figured it'd be
easier for them
take me to the county jail and they had
their their way of getting back
from what when what happened to their so
you spent most of your life
in prison yeah how many i mean how many
years
in prison 40 i'm 53 so probably 40 40
years out of those 53 in prison oh wow
i'd be out i mean i'd be out for about a
week or so
and i wind up you know doing something
you know
doing somebody a favor putting in work
and go right back
it really didn't matter to me back then
you know
because that's i mean that's that's
that's that's
that's what i knew that's that's what i
thought was was normal
but it wasn't you no did you have kids
of your own
yeah i have two girls got two daughters
but you of course didn't raise them
because you were in prison
well i mean i i've always been in their
life
not physically there but in prison you
know i mean i
i learned how to tattoo i was selling
dope and everything so
they always had money whatever they
needed they they got it
you know but it's just i wasn't i wasn't
actually physically there
yeah for them
and you're you so you've been out now
for how long
i've been i've been out five years five
years yeah off parole and everything
right
and what what about drugs were drugs a
party allowed yeah
i was i was born i was born a drug baby
i died i died a couple of times during
that time because i was i was premature
um i really didn't have a choice in the
matter
of choosing to use drugs because my mom
got me started on heroin when i was 10
years old
you know they would push me through
windows and little spots where they
couldn't get in
they would use me and come on yeah but
since that first time your mom
introduced you to heroin
you continued
and you're still using today yeah every
once in a while
not not like before but you know i wound
up getting congestive heart failure
because of that you know so now i have
to take care of myself a little bit more
but instead of taking the narcotics that
the doctors want to give me
i'll just do a little shot of some
heroin you know
it's it's better than being strung on on
four different types of
you know narcotic pills yeah you know
but
my choice i i i don't
i don't i don't like i don't like to use
anymore
but every once in a while i need to
because my organs hurt my blood
pressure's so high all the time
which you would run i'd say 200 over 180
so my organs are shutting down so little
by little i'm dying
so everything that all my enemies and
everything wanted to do back
back in the days when i was banging
yourself i did it to myself yeah
you know you lived an interesting life
the abuse you had to watch in your
childhood and then the gangs and the
prison and drugs and all this
what have you learned from all this i
learned it
did in a way it was a waste of time
but if i hadn't gone through all those
things that i did i wouldn't think the
way i do today
and i wouldn't have been able to meet
people
that i met which are good-sided people
and i wouldn't be able
to teach my little homies the right and
the wrong things to do
you know the right and wrong things to
do so you'll you'll take some of the
young kids
aside and tell them i whipped their ass
you know i mean oh i whipped it i
whipped it behind
you know all that robbing old people
snatching purses
doing [ __ ] in the neighborhood the the
there's no
it's uncalled for yeah they they
they they know better you know
but that's us taking it taking the time
to teach them and show them okay look
this is what you got to do
kiddo you know people
make fun and they they clown about well
why are you fighting over a street
corner
we check it out that street corner that
you're fighting for
in the long run is going to generate
thousands and thousands of dollars
that's why people fight over street
corners like that
not because you know it is you know it's
my neighborhood
we're going to fight overnight it
doesn't work like that
you know it's money at the end of the
day so it's always ulterior motive to
everything
you know just have you have to have
common sense
because everybody that's in a gang has
their position
there's some gunners you can't be
dealers
and there's some dealers they're not cut
out to be gunners
you know you got the ones that got to
give the gap they can talk and
lure in you know females to have them
you know drive dope across the border
whatever
and you got the ones that they're just
straight knuckleheads just savages
don't have a problem with picking up a
gun boom shooting somebody in the head
and
they just you just go get some deep you
know
and you got the dope dealers you know
real smart
you know they know how to generate money
and that's the thing
you just generate money you know
but in my gang
we teach the youngsters to treat
everybody as family
you know you it's it's like being in the
marines or an army
you know you leave nobody behind you
know
and if somebody does leave somebody back
like that then you know
consequences are pretty pretty um pretty
bad
did you find the integrity of the gang
life is
deteriorated over the years yeah no it
is because because of speed crystal meth
see crystal me everybody uses crystal
meth because they're ways
everybody's using it but not everybody's
cut out to use that type of drug
just like not everybody's using is not
everybody's cut out to use heroin
or to use crack you know i know people
that have
used [ __ ] crystal meth for two months
and went crazy
i know others that have used it for
years and they're okay
you know a little bit off the rocker you
know what i mean but just
they're still okay to a certain point
you know
but and how um how what the connection
between drugs and gangs
gang life how tight is that i mean what
do you mean
are there gang members that are that are
totally steering clear of drugs or
yeah or is it kind of yeah i mean
there's some that are
some that aren't you know it just
depends on the individual
because you mean not everybody knows but
you know we all have addictive
personalities to some point
you know like we use cigarettes for
candy
some people leave drugs for six
you know it just it depends it depends
on the individual
and it depends in the hierarchy of the
gang the the
showing these youngsters what it is that
they need to do
you know that's the whole point if you
if you got if you got shitty ass
shitty ass older older homies that are
for your hood
and i wash my hands i steer i still
clear everything
then of course that that gang is going
to be [ __ ]
you know they're going to be doing [ __ ]
it's not
there's nowhere even close to where it
was back in the day
you know back in the day everybody had a
little bit of integrity at least
now it's like ain't ain't no ain't no
morals
no scruples ain't nothing you know
everybody's doing
doing what they want to do and that's
what makes us the bet
you know that's what gives us a bad name
you know which i mean
it's criminal activity anyways but at
least
you know you can stop drive-bys and you
can stop you know a lot of things from
from happening
if given the opportunity you know
what's your opinion of the gang life i
mean what would you tell a young man
who's considering
joining a gang today
i mean
a person is going to do what they're
going to do no matter what
but what i would tell them is if you're
gonna do that
do it a hundred percent or don't do it
at all
because you can wind up dead or you're
gonna wind up somewhere in the alley oh
deep you know
but whatever it is that person is gonna
gonna decide to do
you know make me make it make it a
hundred percent of you know
what you what you're gonna do because
you have step something
you know you're going to want to [ __ ] it
up anyways
but as far as is
telling him not to join the gang
i mean all that energy that he's going
to be you know
exercising toward being you know from
the gang putting in work
do it or do something to where it's
going to help your people
or help people like us you know what i
mean
you know make us come up
he eats i you go down
i'm gonna go down you know
and that's the pretty that's that's
that's the problem not not
just not too much not too much common
sense anymore
you know that chris that crystal
mechanics and and now now it's like
fentanyl
it's [ __ ] people are pretty bad to
where
they just want to you know
be deviant sex offenders and [ __ ] like
that and
now in jail i think like 70 percent of
the population they're all dropouts
i'm not a dropout i'm still active i
must stay active till the day i die
but you know i know now
what i can do and what i can't do and
you know when to do it i'm not just
going to go do something dumb like i
like
like i did before i would do before i
thought
you know now i now i think and
if i continue to keep sweating the small
things like i did before
i'll be i'm gonna be right back you know
for killing somebody
you know or being or beating [ __ ] out of
being somebody because i got like 15
strikes anyways
you know but yeah
that's that's what i would that's what i
would tell somebody if they they
approached me and asked me about that
you know what's the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
there's a few things there's a few
things that i've learned but
hmm yes that's that that's an
interesting question right there
um
probably patience
patience to not you know
jump to going to make and make a mistake
that you're going to regret later on
that's what i would that's that's what i
would say patience
yeah sometimes if you just sit back
things kind of work themselves out
yeah without you getting some people
believe in karma
some people don't but for people that do
believe in karma
everything all comes back everything bad
you do
it all comes back sometimes you might
pay with watching your kids go through
the same [ __ ] or
or what you despise and hate the most
you watch your kids become that and
there's nothing you can do about it
you know you have to see you have to sit
back and just
and just if they have to hit rock bottom
they're going to hit rock bottom
and you know all you can do is just you
know be there for them
kids are going to do what you do not
what you say yeah
all right carlos thank you so much for
sharing your story for sure i wish you
the best of luck
thank you thank you man all right
you